[Music]
hello there over the years how many
players do you think you've played a
game of fortnite with i asked my discord
to tell me the typical fortnite players
they find when they click on squad phil
so now i can bring you 25 types of
fortnite teammate let me know which one
you've met and if you fall into any of
these categories yourself
let's start with one we've all met the
loot goblin everything is going well
until an enemy drops their loot and
that's what triggers the loot goblin
this member of the team won't care if
they got the alim or not they are
straight in there grabbing all the best
weapons and items for themselves some of
these will carry shockwaves to repel
their teammates away after a battle so
they can loot without any pressure
they're just plain greedy but wait if
you're lucky you'll find a giver
this guy asks what weapons you prefer
and looks out for them for you they want
to play as a squad and keep everyone
happy and working together they usually
keep an eye on people's health too
throwing you a couple of minis if you
need it the fortnite giver is an
all-round good guy the next type of
player will leave you the second you're
all on the battle bus the solo these
players see their own teammates as
competition and must finish the game
with moral limbs they look to steal
kills whenever they can and make
decisions to help themselves and not the
team they tend to be sweaty players who
use squad phil to feed their own ego the
thing is should that solo go down early
they usually leave the game and don't
say a word their ego can't take it do
you have a friend who is the sweat
assassin these guys just want to play
with their friends for fun and hide away
their real ability they are great at
fortnite but downplayed their skills
because having fun is more important to
them that's until they see a rival sweat
taking advantage of their teammates that
is the sweat assassins moment to evolve
and fight back they can crank with the
best of them they can take out the rival
sweat and immediately go back to playing
casually these players could go pro but
they leave their egos at the door when
they're playing squad phil at some point
you're gonna meet a fanboy as soon as
the names pop up in the top left corner
they are already looking at the end for
the logo of the platform you play on
they want to know if you're on
playstation xbox pc or switch they want
to start a mini console war or proclaim
they are in the master race these
players are toxic to the core and like
most toxic fanboys all you have to do is
mute them and another trick is if they
get downed don't revive them nobody
wants a console war and what about this
one we all know at least one person who
is the combo king or queen these players
aren't here to win games they are here
to admire every skin on the battlefield
you could be under fire from three teams
and the combo guy will comment on how
well your back bling goes with your
weapon rap the strange thing is when
eliminated they keep watching and rate
the combos of the person who eliminated
them have you ever been in squad phil
when the foreigner arrives they come
into chat and start speaking a language
you don't understand usually your love
of fortnite can get you through the
whole experience and a quick google
gives you a few basic words to reply
it's a little more unsettling when you
are the foreigner in the group and the
other three people are talking to each
other effortlessly and you don't have a
clue what's going on
and i'm sure you've met the afk guy they
are in the squad taking part and
suddenly they say i'll be right back and
the thing is this could be 30 seconds or
30 minutes or sometimes more so you're
left with a conundrum do you leave them
to die in the storm or do you find a way
to drag them into each circle whatever
you choose the second they get knocked
they get back on mic and what is squad
phil without a kid in the world's
loudest house they're usually great
people they just want to have some fun
the only problem is everything behind
them is so loud it hurts your ears and
within five minutes you've probably
heard their mother in the background
shouting at their sister oh and
sometimes they play music it's always
really bad music too when will they find
the mute function do you know anyone who
is obsessed with completing the daily
and weekly challenges these players will
ignore the other three markers on the
map to land somewhere completely away
from everyone else they aren't doing
this to be spiteful oh no they just want
to get their challenges done and the
best place to do that is in a squad fill
game once the task is done they usually
leave completely mid game they simply
used you and your team to get challenges
done
ouch now what about the fake sweats the
players who want to look as intimidating
as possible and wear skins associated to
sweaty pro players they have a star wand
a soccer skin a superhero skin and look
for fights and then reality hits they
aren't that good and go down early
they'll then constantly pressure you to
reboot them as soon as possible one
teammate we could all use is the
protector players like this will try
their best to keep you alive risking
themselves in the process they'll scoop
you up and try their best to stop your
body from exploding these guys see
picking up a reboot card as failure the
protector wants the team to win but only
when all members are still alive and
kicking on the other hand there's the
backseat gamer the person who has been
eliminated so early but that won't shut
them up they use their mic to tell you
exactly what to do they're demeaning and
off-putting their call-outs are dreadful
and they find any way to bring you down
they don't want anyone else to succeed
because they failed themselves but wait
there's another type of backseat gamer
who is great the angel yes they may have
taken a shotgun to the dome in the first
circle but they don't leave the game or
become toxic they watch you play and
give out helpful info they will tell you
how many builds you have left they'll
tell you if you need to reload or how
far away the storm is they're happy the
team can still win and will be a part of
it any way they can they are pretty much
an angel on your shoulder have you met
the new type of squad phil player this
season the one who loves crowns thanks
to the new emote and mechanic to follow
this metric you'll likely meet a person
who instantly must show you how many
crowns they've got the second they meet
you they are so proud of themselves but
let's be serious if they don't have
exactly 69 crowns they are useless next
we have the anime fan
next on the list we have the leaker they
have the notifications on for hypex's
tweets and tells you everything it can
be mid-game and even though you don't
want spoilers they're gonna share every
single word a leaker tells them which
means you have to sit through and listen
oh and don't get me started on the ttv
guys everyone wants to be a successful
streamer or content creator these days
and that leads to people putting ttv or
yt in their names twitch youtube some of
them will be streaming right at this
moment and they will talk to their chat
mid-fight the thing is if you look at
their twitch chat you can see that it
has two viewers and you're one of them
the ttvs will fake it until they make it
have you ever met a flexer you may be
thinking these people are highly skilled
but oh no no no they come to flex the
latest skin in the item shop every day
it's a new skin and they have the money
to buy them some flexers don't even know
they're flexing whereas others are
dedicated to it they'll wear limited
edition skins on days when the fortnite
shop isn't that great playstation xbox
nvidia switch all the skins that are
super rare they own them all and they
will flex them every opportunity they
get and yeah occasionally i will be
found admiring their skins
there are some damn good skins in
fortnite
these players are usually the item shop
guy too picture this it's one minute
until the shop updates you're in a fight
in the final circle of the game and
suddenly they disconnect they completely
deserted you because winds are nothing
near as important as watching the star
update this group of players will even
watch other people reviewing the store
every day it's a weird habit but it's
completely great if they use cold adam
mario worth a try speaking of skins do
you know a teammate who demands matching
skins sometimes it's identical skins and
sometimes it's about a theme for example
if you put on a dc skin they have to do
it too and suddenly you have four
batman's in one squad all four joneses
are four of the seven or 16 bananas bum
rushing people in team rumble that was
fun have you been in a squad with a
reminiscer this person does like
fortnite but always thinks it's besties
are behind it they'll remember old times
like the shopping cart being released or
the game being void of skill-based
matchmaking they'll talk about the first
live events and by the end of the game
you'll miss 2018 almost as much as them
the reminiscers are dangerous and then
there's the guy who absolutely hates
fortnite from the first minute they'll
go on about how apex legends is the
better game or how h1z1 is the best
battle royale they hate fortnite with a
passion but guess what they can't stop
playing it and that makes them so angry
and toxic they'll tell you every game
that's better and that you should not be
playing fortnite the thing is if apex
legends was that good you'd be playing
it right now you don't need validation
from us i wonder if you have this guy on
your friends list the dude with the
crappy internet in game they'll rubber
band around and cause other teams so
many issues but ping aside the real
issue is update day they'll need five
days to download the latest patch and
you have to wait for them the pain
starts now and that brings us to the
troll these guys deliberately queue in
duos or squads to troll you all they
want is to upset you that's how they
feel joy sadly back in 2018 friendly
fire was a thing and these guys would
deliberately shoot their own teammates
to cause issues and four years later
they still do it but now shooting isn't
an option they've found other ways they
will chop down your builds to make you
take fall damage in the no builds mode
they will deliberately shoot your cover
so you are left exposed and lots of them
now carry shock waves with them to throw
you into the storm the troll is a
nightmare i just don't think they have
many friends at home maybe we should all
hug a troll
so there we have it 25 people you meet
in fortnite thank you very much to my
discord for helping me with this list
and here's some other videos you could
click and some names of some legends who
used code adamaru this week thank you so
much for using my code i'm adam you're
awesome see you next time